TO.
>> TRUMP HAS DONE SO MUCH TO
POLITICIZE IT, HE HAS US STUCK.
>> SWITCHING GEARS NOW.
>> I WANT YOU TO KNOW, I HAD
PERMISSION TO HUG LONNY.
HE GAVE ME PERMISSION TO TOUCH
HIM.
[
LAUGH
>> JOE BIDEN JOKING AFTER
SEVERAL WOMEN ACCUSED HIM OF
UNCOMFORTABLE TOUCHING.
BIDEN ANSWERED QUESTIONS ABOUT
THE ALLEGATIONS.
>> WELL, I WOULDN'T BE
SURPRISED.
I'VE HAD HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS
OF PEOPLE CONTACT ME, WHO I
DON'T KNOW.
YOU KNOW, SAY THE EXACT
OPPOSITE.
I'M SORRY, I DIDN'T UNDERSTAND
MORE.
I'M NOT SORRY FOR ANY OF MY
INTENTIONS, NOT SORRY FOR
ANYTHING THAT I HAVE EVER DONE.
I'VE NEVER BEEN DISRESPECTFUL
INTENTIONALLY.
THE
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP IS WEIGHING
IN, HE'S TROLLING BIDEN ON
TWITTER WITH THIS PARITY VIDEO.
>> I HUG PEOPLE, I GRAB MEN AND
WOMEN BY THE SHOULDERS AND SAY,
YOU CAN DO THIS.
AND WOMEN, MEN, YOUNG, OLD, THAT
IS THE WAY I'VE ALWAYS BEEN AND
I TRY TO SHOW I CARE ABOUT THEM
AND I'M LISTENING.
>> THE FORMER VICE PRESIDENT
QUICKLY RESPONDED BY CALLING
PRESIDENT TRUMP "PRESIDENTIAL AS
ALWAYS," WHAT DO YOU THINK
EMILY?
>> TODAY WE SAW THE OLD BIDEN
AND NEW BIDEN, HE SHINED IN MY
OPINION, IN FRONT OF THE UNION
AUDIENCE.
HE EXHIBITED WHAT PROPELLED HIM
TO SUCCESS IN THE PAST, WHICH
WAS VERY RELATABLE AND
COMFORTABLE AND HEY, WE'RE ALL
IN THE SAME BOAT, MAKING THAT
JOKE.
AFTER THAT PRESSER, I WAS STRUCK
BY WHAT I FELT WAS HIM BEING
ARCAIC, THE DEFINITION OF
PROGRESSIVE, IT SEEMS TO BE
CHANGING, ALMOST CONFUSED.
IT SEEMED WHILE IT MIGHT
RESONATE WITH OLDER VOTERS IN
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY, IT DIDN'T
SEEM HE HAD RELEVANCE THAT I CAN
SEE THAT CAN GALVANNIZE THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, NEEDED TO WIN
THE PRIMARY.
I THOUGHT HE WAS SADLY OUT OF
TOUCH.
>>THE INTERESTING.
JESSE, I NOTICED ALL WEEK THAT
REPUBLICANS HAVE BEEN IN HIS
CORNER ON THIS SAYING MAYBE
#MeToo MOVEMENT GONE TOO FAR.
I THOUGHT, INTERESTING.
IS IT THE CASE THAT REPUBLICANS
MAY WANT JOE BIDEN, MAYBE NICKED
UP AND DAMAGED AS FOIL FOR TRUMP
IN 2020?
>> WE LIKE TO SEE THE DEMOCRATS
DAMAGED IF THEY RUN AGAINST
TRUMP, THAT IS OBVIOUS.
BIDEN HANDLED HIMSELF NICE
TODAY.
NICE ICE BREAKER, THE JOKE.
HE DID THE GAGGLE AND SEEMED
RELAXED AND CONFIDENT AND TRIED
TO MAKE SURE EVERYBODY
UNDERSTOOD HE WAS NOT BEING
PERVERTED, THAT IS WHAT NEEDS TO
COME ACROSS, HE IS ARCHAIC OR
GOOFY.
HE DID STRUGGLE WHEN TRYING TO
DEFINE IDEOLOGICALLY WHERE HE
WAS, PROGRESSIVE, MODERATE,
DEMOCRAT, HE STUCK THE LANDING
AND SAID I'M AN OBAMA-BIDEN
DEMOCRAT, THAT IS WHERE HE NEEDS
STAY.
HE'S MOVING INTO THE ELIZABETH
WARREN TERRITORY, WHATEVER SHE
SAYS DOESN'T MATTER, EVERYBODY
JUST THINKS FAKE INDIAN.
NOW IF YOU GET THE CONSTANT
TRICKLE OF WOMEN COMING OUT
SAYING HE VIOLATED MY PERSONAL
SPACE WEEK AFTER WEEK AFTER
WEEK, EVERY TIME YOU SEE BIDEN,
YOU DON'T THINK ABOUT THE
SPEECH, YOU THINK CREEPY JOE.
>> HMM.
YOU KNOW, DANA, WHO STRIKES ME
HERE, THIS OPENS THE DOOR TO A
LOT OF QUESTIONS ABOUT JOE
BIDEN'S PAST, OBVIOUSLY THE
ANITA HILL HEARING WOULD BE
LARGE.
ALSO HIS SUPPORT FOR BUSINESS,
THE FACT HE OPPOSED PARTIAL
BIRTH ABORTION FOR A WHILE, THE
PLAGIARISM CHARGES AGAINST HIM
30 YEARS AGO.
>> NOT TO MENTION, HE SUPPORTED
THE IRAQ WAR.
>> NICE SUMMARY, JUAN, THAT WAS
GOOD.
>> VERY WATER WORLD.
>> I'M RUBBING OFF.
>> THAT IS PROBLEM TELLING
PEOPLE THE FACTS.
>> OKAY, JUAN, SHUT UP.
IN 2008, YOU REMEMBER WHAT WAS
THE DEAL BETWEEN McCAIN AND
OBAMA?
McCAIN HAD A REALLY LONG RECORD
AND OBAMA WAS LIKE HELPING
CHANGE.
IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT IS HAPPENING
WITH THE DEMOCRATS, THEY MIGHT
LOVE JOE BIDEN AND THEY MIGHT
THINK HE COULD BE THE BEST
CANDIDATE, BUT HE HAS ALL OF
THESE THINGS THAT A NEW
DEMOCRATIC PARTY DOESN'T WANT.
WE SAY THAT ON THE SHOW, EVERY
TIME THE POLLING COMES OUT ABOUT
BIDEN, WE TALK ABOUT THINGS WILL
BE HARD, HE STAYS AT THE TOP IN
THE DEMOCRATIC POLLS.
>> IT IS NOT CLOSE.
HE MIGHT TAKE A HIT NOW.
ONE OTHER THING, I KNOW WHERE
YOU ARE GOING WITH THAT, I
AGREE.
IN THE FOX NEWS VOTER ANALYSIS
OF 2016, WHATEVER WE CALLED IT
AT THAT POINT.
ONE OF THE NUMBER ONE THINGS IN
ALL OF THOSE PRIMARY DEBATES AND
THE VOTING IS THAT REPUBLICANS
SAID WE LIKE HIM, TRUMP, BECAUSE
HE TELLS IT LIKE HE IS.
WE WANT SOMEONE WHO WILL TELL US
LIKE IT IS.
THE THING BIDEN COULD DO IS TELL
IT LIKE HE IS, BUT HE'S NOT
QUITE THERE.
>> ONE THING IN THE SPEECH,
THOUGH --
>> JUST SAY AGREE.
>> I THOUGHT IT WAS GREAT, GOOD
FOR HIM, THAT IS HOW YOU FIGHT
IT.
HE IS NOT BEING ACCUSED OF
SEXUAL HARASSMENT, TAKING
SOMEBODY IN THE BACK CORNER AND
SAYING HE WAS INAPPROPRIATE.
THEY ARE SAYING I DIDN'T LIKE
THE WAY HE HUGGED ME.
IS A LINE THERE, DIFFERENT
THING.
GOOD TO FIGHT BACK WITH A JOKE
AND GREAT TO CLEARLY NOT BE
CREEPY WHEN THERE IS CHILDREN
PRESIDENT.
HE HAD A GOOD DAY, I WAS PROUD
AND HAPPY.
>> I WONDER HOW DEMOCRATS TAKE
IT, THOUGH, RIGHT?
>> LOOK AT THAT SHOT.
>> WHERE ARE WE?
>> PUT IT IN BLACK AND WHITE,